here in scarborough political squabbles
feel a thousand miles away
but the decisions made in westminster
affect us all and they're shifting
political sands
order not everyone in boris johnson's
party agrees with his plan to hike taxes
for working people but tonight mps voted
for it the ice to the right
319
the nose to the left
248. just a handful of tory mps rebelled
questioning how conservative the policy
really is the conservative party at some
stage in our lifetimes
is going to have to rediscover what it
stands for because i have to say at the
moment we keep doing things we hate
because we feel we must this tax
is not really a health and social care
tax it's actually a trojan horse
for an nhs tax
so i just think this huge danger for for
us in creating such a hypothetical tax
and having it on people's pay slips it
is fundamentally
unconservative
in response ministers warned there is no
alternative the system needs fixing now
this levy will enable the biggest
catch-up initiative in the history of
the nhs a comprehensive long-term
solution to the social care challenge a
significant long-term investment which
will directly improve people's lives but
labour accused the government of making
the wrong choices yet failed to provide
a clear alternative themselves there are
choices and they are difficult ones this
government is choosing to tax ordinary
working-class people on this side of the
house we would ask those with the
broader shoulders the wealthiest in our
communities to pay more this government
make a different choice they can justify
that to their constituents
back in scarborough those on the social
care front line just want a plan that
works and they worry this one won't
people are still going to have to
perhaps sell a house eventually to pay
for the care because accommodation costs
and food costs are not included in that
cap that's a critical bit when you get
to the small print people realize it's
not quite as exciting as people have
been led to believe but it's a start we
must welcome the beginning of something
new that's coming
boris johnson hopes he can turn the tide
on years of poor social care but he's
taking a huge risk both with his party's
loyalty and with people's lives kate
mccann sky news